The joe rogan experience.
If you're around the kid enough,
it changes who you are and
if you're not around the kid,
that changes who you are because then
you realize you're not around the kid and
that's going to take a piece out of who
you think you are. But you know what?
If if you,
if you and we have friends who aren't
great dads or whatever and you could see
it in their kids, I can I, and I'm,
I'm not slowing up psychologist
or I'm some expert in parenting,
but if I go to a person's house and I see
the way the kids treat the pants, I go,
you're not around enough,
man. I promise you.
I can tell my son doesn't act like that.
Yeah,
because one thing that you can call me
whatever you want, whenever you want.
One thing I am is a beast of a dad. I
know that. I don't know if I'm good comic.
I don't know if I was a good fighter.
I don't want from good podcasts are,
that's all up for debate. One thing I
know is I'm a fucking good dad, man.
Good for you, man. That's
a, it's a very, very, very,
very important quality and that quality,
when your kid becomes an adult,
that's going to be, which is a major
factor in how you get along. I give you,
I mean even parents,
I know friends who had
had bad relationships with
their parents when they live
with them and then once they got out,
their parents were nice to them with
the parents was shitty to them when they
were kids and they always
hold it against always.
They always have that shit in
the back of their head. Like,
why were you a dick when I was 12 you
know that that shit is always in their
head. It's like that Avatar
horse when you're young, you,
you mixed together and if you don't
make scale of when you're young,
and I was talking to someone,
a therapist, they were saying,
I think it's from like til they're three.
If you don't make that connection. Yeah.
When when you're like, oh,
when they're for like, oh,
I'll do it now it's almost
too late because they already
developed these, this,
these brain pathways were like,
Nope,
my dad's an ass and there's really
nothing you can do to fix it. Yeah man.
I went to the movies yesterday
with my kid, my movie.
We went to see the GNOMEO and Juliet.
Oh yeah. What is it? A Sherlock gnomes?
Yeah, the sure like, no, I'm so
cute little movie, but you know,
we went to that synopsis place
when you know you lean back,
you know those things. Seats, lean
back, good food and you take the, uh,
the seat rests down and she just,
my seven year old just
snuggles with me Macbeth,
they're snuggling watching a movie.
I'm like, I couldn't be happier.
I don't want to see this stupid
fucking movie. No, but I don't care.
She wants to so I couldn't be happier.
I sat there and watched us.
Silly knows shit moving.
She just a little snuggle bunny.
I've watched her last baby nine
times by time. Not a bad mood.
And like a week though, that's pretty
funny movie. The boss, baby's great.
Alcohol is the voice I watched like nine
times, but with my son, whenever watch,
he snuggled up when? When? Usually
this is why I want a daughter.
That's why I'm jealous you have daughters
because daughters loved their dads.
My son. I'm like, you
little traitor mommy,
mommy like dude, it's me every morning.
Your car for your mom cross like that too.
And a lot of ways it's,
you got to accept the fact that the mom
is not just the soft sweet woman in the
house,
but she's also the person who made them
in the her body and there's chemical
connection of her body. Man is
like, I had to deal with my wife.
Like I'm not naming any kids.
I go, I got veto power. I go,
but you do way more work. Like it's
way harder to make the person I go.
As long as you tried to call the kid
applesauce or something. Fucking stupid.
Yeah. You know, I just
don't feel like it's,
it's not even proposition. Oh, I did
this fucker, we're going to do anyways,
but now we own it with this seed.
You know what, you've got a bonus.
Get a bonus overtime for you.
It is kind of crazy though,
that sex is how you make people I know
and everybody wants just wants to fuck
all the time and you want
to fuck a bunch of people.
A lot of people don't
like kids. No. Hell No.
You know who opened my eyes like in a
big way in a podcast recently that's
really been making me think a lot
about this is Bret Weinstein. He's the,
the professor that gotten that.
Do you know the,
you know we is controversy with the
Evergreen University and all that and they
were taking the day, it wasn't a pronoun
thing, it was the day of absence.
They wanted it all the white people to
stay home and he's like, that's racist.
Yeah. Anyway, he was on,
you said there's two different
things that men are attracted to.
They're attracted to a woman that they
think would be a great companion and a
great mother and like someone who,
he said there's a difference between
hot and beautiful. Correct. Like,
some women are beautiful and like they're
loving you want to be around them.
I goes,
but then there's other women who are
just hot and in males that very receptive
woman who doesn't require any commitment
was an opportunity for men to spread
their seed with someone who they didn't
have to be around for. Wow. Yeah,
so there's literally like a
programming in a man's mind.
So you see a girl with big giant tits
and a little waist and a fat ass hanging
out of her shorts and she's got sloppy
makeup on and she looks at you and you're
like, oh, okay, let's do
this. But that's what that is.
It's not like you let,
you're not saying,
I would like to start a relationship
with you. It's like, no,
I want to shoot my load in to you,
and then you raise my kid when I'm nowhere
near you because it's an opportunity
for my DNA to propagate. Wow. So
much sense. It makes so much sense.
I literally never considered it until
he brought it up on the podcast. I went,
oh Duh. Me Neither. I just thought
she's hot. Whatever. She's just hot,
dirty in a dirty way. Why she's
attracted to that. Why is she so dirty?
I told my girl, Joe, I told my girl,
Joe, probably four weeks into it,
five weeks we were getting serious and
she got this job offer to go to Miami and
she's talking about career and stuff like
that. And I went, no, that's all cool.
It's all and no one's career first
more than me. However, uh, you know,
you're put on the search to be a mom,
right?
Like you're can be such a beast of a mom.
I guarantee you,
because I saw her interact with
Callan's kids. I can guarantee you,
you might be the greatest
host in the world,
but you're going to be the best mom I've
ever seen. And then she's like, really?
I'm like, I guarantee you
fucking Bam Bam. Well,
that's just those
qualities that you can see.
It's something and when someone's not,
when someone's a bad mom,
it's such a depressed man.
Nothing worse.
So depressing to be around woman is like
really short with her kids and shitty
with them and like,
oh well even as a kid,
if I had friends who like talk back to
their pants are mean to their pants. Like,
Oh God, what's wrong with you? If I was
dating a girl, she'd like bad mouth,
their mom. Like what's wrong with you
girl know the hard thing is that pattern.
It's hard to break.
Those kids may very well have that same
kind of behavior towards their kids.
Like when they become adults,
it's a hard pattern to break.
Sometimes you need the
right person in your life.
It's like a good person in
your life that you, you know,
a wife or husband or whoever it is.
You know when you,
you match up at that person,
like it changes who you are too.
That's what I always say that one of
the most important things about, um,
community, like your community of
friends is when you have good friends,
those people change you.
Like you react.
Like everyone is your tribe.
You react like everyone's your friends.
So you want good for them. You
love them, you care about them.
They change who you are. They change
and they inspire you or they eat.
Whether they inspire you with being smart
or their kindness or their ambition,
whatever it is that we're are,
we're not individuals.
We're a piece of a community
always and that community,
even if it's a small community
that you call a family,
that piece is dependent upon
who you do that piece with. A,
you might be an amazing dad with the
right woman, but with the wrong woman,
you might be so frustrated
with the relationship that
you're not as good at data
right now. There might be
chaos going on all the time.
You might be situations you put the kid
in when you're yelling and screaming at
each other,
the kitchen,
see all these different factors that are
dependent upon your relationship with
this other person and they
changed you and you change them.
Like you might be the
wrong person for them.
They might be super cool
and calm with someone else,
but with you it's just not a Mitch.
It doesn't hit buttons.
It's like a woman saying to you, uh,
you know, you don't want an equal like,
well I don't want this. I don't
want this. No, I don't want this.
You might be right. But I know for sure
I don't want them. You're threatened.
You threatened by a strong woman. No,
I'm talking about you. You're just,
you're aggressive for no reason.
Who the fuck has ever said that
you threatened by strong man.
It's run by a strong
man. Like what? Shut up.
Cause he was he calling yourself a
strong man. Get the fuck out of here.
Any guy who calls himself a strong man
like that job most likely's up pitch.
Most likely.
It's just trying to prop himself.
And I feel the same way about women who
say that women who were like, you know,
you're scared of a strong woman. Like
okay, am I really or are you a con? Yup.
Just raging cause it's this con talk.
This sounds like this guy sounds all
to them. Again, super uncomfortable.
I don't know what got us to this position,
but whatever I did please,
I'll apologize. But I
also feel like in, in,
in this community of friends that were
talking about if you are a shit father,
it would show elsewhere in your life
around us or if we're at the comedy store
or a restaurant or in your,
in your social media,
it's going to come out one way or
another. You know, when you know,
that would be tough to be in that group.
You know the expression,
how you do one thing is how you
do everything. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
I think there's something to that.
I mean obviously there's people that
are really good at one thing and suck at
other things. So it's not a, it's
not always a hundred percent correct.
But you know, if you're a shitty dad,
you're going to be a shitty friend. Agree.
And if you're a shitty friend, you're
probably going to be shitty. Dad,
and I say this too,
with like with due to our shitty debt,
dad's, it's like right. If you're
willing to do that to, you're literally,
you're connected this person chemically,
they're, they're made of your DNA.
If you want to treat him like that
when the going gets rough for me,
where the fuck are you going
to be? There's no way I
want you my foxhole. Yeah.
Yeah. That's big man. And then people
that don't, they don't understand that.
They don't understand what they're doing
wrong. That's rough too. The bummer.
The people that can't see it and you
try to explain it to them and they can't
see it. The one thing people will put up
with those, and I would never do this,
but if you give someone parenting
advice, it just doesn't, there's just,
there's certain things you can't
talk about. Usually politics,
religion and parenting.
The only way I think parenting advice
works ever is if you talk about one great
thing that you found that you do with
your kid without criticizing another yes,
you could.
You could give them advice but not give
them advice by like you can relay your
personal positive experiences and
either they take it or they don't.
But as soon as you start saying,
hey man,
I see how you talked to
your son and you're like,
what the fuck did you say people
get your son is a, you know,
he's an individual man. He treated
her autism. An object like fuck,
I don't fucking treat my son. Like Austin
came over, he's not even listening.
What you said you're all ramping up.
My son was one and a half at the
time and I was taken to this,
this play area and he,
you know,
he did not express himself and everyone
was older and you tick kids and he's a
big kid.
He's 99% tile for size and all that stuff.
And he would hit kids and the,
the place where I was taking him in
Brentwood knew I was a former fighter.
One of the guys who works
front desk as a fan.
I've talked with MMA with them and they
took me to the side and said, you know,
we, we got a bit of a problem cause tiger
is a hitting kids and we think it's in
direct correlation of you let
them watch fights. And from,
I just started laughing. You
guys are silly as fuck. I'm a,
I'm never bring him back.
B, he's one and a half.
Everyone else in their s three I mean,
yeah,
he cold cock that kid with a
left hook and I'm proud of them.
I could took his toy. However, it's
just, this is what kids do. They hit man,
it's nothing. And we, and I tell him,
no, I'm staying on top of my helicopter.
The pennant, the fuck out him when he's
in there. But these, these one and a half,
there was kids who are older and
I've trust me, he's not watching UFC.
It's not has nothing to do it.
They think this lady was like that.
You have F C or whatever you're getting
into. And I was like, oh my God,
this is some Brent. Which
shit lady. There's a lot of
some which shit right now.
All right, yellow, yellow, meet dirt. If
they hit each other, they hate each other.
We're concerned that you are
constantly reaffirming his
gender without him choosing.
We're concerned.
Okay.